[Music]  we're going to show you wallflowers the  perks of real  flowers watch out  wayne you're going the wrong way you  want to go because we can go right now  this message is transmitted at the  request of the united states office of  civil defense we are under siege by a  chemical attack  how bad is it it's  not that bad  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  we need to find weapons if you get us  killed i'm gonna be so pissed  what do you suggest we do i say draw  them to one side of the building and  then slip through the other one  i'm a dnd level 20 raw wizard hey  protect us  what is it with you shut-ins and zombie  fantasy we're on the goddamn comic book  okay  whoa watch the doll chase  is is he dead  of course he's dead ryan he just rolled  the freaking room  what we need  is fire  [Music]  more like  out watch badass  [Music]  you